can i play all right you want Calvin
Jamal they play the same game no one's
gonna recruit you I'm a ballplayer what
a jacked up attitude they share the same
dream you'd love him to play USC like
you did right I left for him to get a
good education tomboy thing I won't I'm
a lesbian that's not funny yo look how
bad you even how about a little
one-on-one and what we plan it for I
score some strip take it off take it oh
I love investing Oh beep
there's only one way to be successful at
anything and that is to give everything
coach has a son of them o'clock curfew I
can stay a few minutes or sweat yes I
don't have it easy like you all right
there's no red carpet laid out for me
and I know ways some soft freshman has
taken my spot
you forgot to beat it if I stain I
wouldn't be starting oh this you got
your priorities straight
look I'm in a draft I'm going pro so
that's it just forget about you and me
[Music]
New Line Cinema presents a story about
the passion it takes I never knew anyone
loved ball as much as you to keep your
dreams alive I've loved you since I was
11 and it just won't go away this spring
I play one game one-on-one for what your
heart all's fair in love and basketball
[Music]
please welcome our host for today's
program director producer writer patty
Jenkins hello I'm so happy to be here
wow I cannot believe it's been 20 years
since love and basketball came out it
was such a great time getting to
re-watch it again recently I'm super
grateful to get to be the one hosting
this panel of an iconographic film I
think one of my favorite things about
the film is is something that has been
noted for many many times which is that
it really it was a game changer in in
the way that it showed people in a
different way than anyone had ever seen
them before for me it was one of the
first times I saw something that spoke
to me about myself as a woman and our
generation and it introduced me to a
world that I didn't know with such
authenticity that it was actually
startling which is such an interesting
experience because you know there are so
many cliches in films that one gets used
to that when you suddenly don't see
those cliches and you see a story being
told in a way that's actually very
truthful to you and your and and the way
you've experienced life it actually is
surprising because it's just as
successful of a story but yet it's not
one you've ever experienced before as
familiar as it is and I found myself
thinking oh my god that's how women
actually feel or that's how things
actually happen or that's how that's why
that's how men actually behave or that's
how these different things so I love the
movie for that reason but what I really
about the movie is that it can be
remembered for those reasons but the
truth is it's a great film that's the
reason that we remember it that's the
reason we talked about it
it's an incredibly confident film it's a
beautifully potent story with a very
avant-garde structure and it's it's
unusually striking visual style that was
also something I'd never seen before the
way the sports were played and the way
that so many of the experiences from the
love scene to the you know just just to
the experience of the whole thing I'd
never seen anything quite like it
but it was effortlessly done and it
makes it a memorable and now modern
classic so let's bring some of the
filmmakers responsible for this piece of
filmmaking first up I'd love to the
welcome a friend appear and a critically
acclaimed director and someone that I
admire and love she exploded onto the
scene as an auteur a filmmaker behind
this film but followed it up with
fantastic Secret Life of Bees and beyond
the lights and I'm really looking
forward to the upcoming old-guard with
my dear friend Charlize thrown off her
Netflix so let's welcome the one and
only Gina Prince Blythewood a hi Gina
thanks for being here thank you so much
and next up let's bring on eleven
basketballs very own Monica in addition
to her incredibly powerful and memorable
performance on this film she's been a
blade in the wood and something new and
contagion and great work on television
and the affair and Family Guy in
nip/tuck and so many other things she
also went on to executive produce and
star in the perfect guy and Napoli ever
after and start creating Herman much of
her own work so her leading performance
in this film was an incredible feat of
acting is she so beautifully rose to the
challenge of giving an amazing
performance but all the while acting
this incredibly sophisticated basketball
playing which she took on completely for
this film which I can't imagine doing
both of those things at once so welcome
the stunningly impressive Sanaa Lathan
thank you so much
such a huge fan so nice to meet you I'm
such a huge fan - so so great to have
you here well next let's bring on
someone I'm going to introduce because I
should and that's what I'm here to do
but the truth is I really don't have to
because she's a legend and we all know
who she is from her fantastic work in
everything from oscar-nominated cross
performance in cross creek to Grand
Canyon to passion fish 12 years of slave
Crooklyn and I'm only naming some of my
favorites so there's a huge body of work
in this film she gives an incredibly
honest performance as Camille right
Monica's mother and she has she's also a
passionate activist with great
achievements including her work for
South Africa and AIDS and serving on
President Obama's Committee for the Arts
I'd love to introduce or or bring on the
exceptional talent we all know and love
alfre woodard hi guys I'm happy so nice
for me to meet you I've never met you
before even though I've always wanted to
so thanks thanks thanks for being here
and so nice to meet you
it's a pleasure Thank You Patti and next
the the young actress who played young
Monica oh my god what an amazing
performance she started acting as a
young child and has an impressive body
of work for someone still so very young
her performance in this film was
startlingly present and skilled for
someone with such a difficult task of
living up to a character being
established by another great actor and
and playing basketball and juggling so
many things she did a beautiful job at
it let's welcome Kyla Pratt's
[Music]
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
I'm so happy to even just be a part of
this so thank you for including me
that's awesome to have you and finally
let's welcome a longtime collaborator of
Gina's a gifted editor with such
wonderful films as Eve's Bayou biker
boys diary of a man
black woman talked to me a Secret Life
of Bees Blackman Nativity and most
recently wonderful work on when they see
us Terrell in Shropshire to have you all
so as I mentioned I'll kick it off with
starting a conversation even though I
know there's so much to say probably
amongst you guys who some of you see
each other all the time but some of you
may not have seen each other hopefully
we'll get to catch up a little bit here
as I mentioned in my introduction one of
my favorite things about the filmmaking
here was the may the way it made me see
the world in a way that I'd never seen
myself and seen you know a familiar
thing but I also I really loved how you
did things like shot the basketball Gina
like I that was so beautifully done I've
never seen it that way again
and it really gave me the experience of
someone who doesn't play basketball of
what it feels like to be in the game and
it made it a very follow a bull story
you know and I think that the work that
you and terilyn did together to make
that a story that I as a non basketball
player was completely following but felt
all of the emotion behind - like where
are you at in it and then in addition
the way you shot even the the the
intimacy scene I'd never seen that
before and that actually got to me and
spoke to me in a way and in the you know
the mother-daughter relationship was
something how did you go about
approaching the filmmaking aspect of
this film mm-hmm well you know your
first film is it was a lot of just
preparation in terms of I think I
watched every single basketball film
that was out at the time and you know
you see the way that things are shot and
and I think it's just natural as a
filmmaker how can you tell it
differently and even more so for that
I'm a ballplayer I sound like Monica but
I mean I was four years old I had a ball
in my hand and I wanted to try and
capture that and let an audience feel
what I feel the joy that I have on court
and the
the emotion and and what it feels like
to be in a game and really really tried
to figure out how we could do that and
this was before the time of GoPros and
and much smaller cameras where you know
it would be easy to do that so it was a
lot of trial and error of how we could
do that and it finally came to lists to
handheld and be be Monica let the camera
be Monica and props to our our
basketball choreographers because it
took such incredible work to make it
work but in addition to that all the
ball players on the floor were girls on
the Crenshaw basketball team so you know
these aren't some people they are their
real ballplayers but I think in essence
that kind of helped with the
authenticity as well but so much of it
was making the camera be Monica but then
also what was important was some nas
boys over in that and again just putting
us in the head of a ball player and what
you feel in the moment and what you're
seeing and I think with the you know
love scene it was it's kind of that same
thing I wanted to put an audience in the
head of what it is to your first time
and I I said to the camera but I I
really have to give all props to non
omar because so much it just it's funny
that scene got in our goddess in our
rating from the MPAA
and they said because it but it felt too
real which is an amazing compliment but
it also pissed me off because there's no
nudity there's it was just focus on
their faces but that's what I wanted to
do is is put an audience in the head of
both the girl and the guy and just the
way that they were looking at each other
and the moments that they clayed that
just felt real of you know a girl taking
her dress off for the first time in
front of this boy that she loves and the
nervousness of that and you know just
just playing all that and again that was
the man Omar bringing so much just
openness to to that scene and and then
I'll give up to Maxwell who just saying
the hell out of that
Kate Bush song woman's work and and it's
so tied to that scene now it's such an
amazing song and it just felt like just
such a great marriage of image and
emotion and music so how does it feel
Gina to look back after all of these
years of what the film has become and
how it's been received there's obviously
the experience of making it and like
you're hoping fingers crossed that it
succeeds and whatever but then it turns
into something else over the 20 years
how does that feel looking back mm-hmm
well well the crazy thing I mean if if I
allowed myself I would cry right now
because I seen this group is it's so
beautiful and I miss all of us and I
miss what we had on that set and I just
wanted like bottle it and just do it
over and over it was just such you know
it was such a special time and you know
I'd to think that this we're talking
about this movie 20 years later is it is
truly surreal because it was so hard to
get it made it was so hard to write it
was so hard to get anyone to believe in
it except for my husband Reggie rock
I'll props to him you know as I've said
every studio turned it down and that is
such a devastating thing to write
something so personal and to take the
leap of faith of writing a spec about a
subject you know a black girl and in a
love story with with black characters I
if they weren't being made but I had to
tell the story and so to put so much
myself in there and put it out to the
world and get crickets you know that
hurt but just things it's so interesting
that things just seem to fall into place
for this film and I truly believe
everything happens for a reason and and
house anak came to be there were so many
times if something had happened
differently she would not be in this
movie and I can't fathom this film
without Sonam to to know I
to get alfred for this film but like i'm
you know this young woman and like why
would Alfre want to be in something that
i wrote but being able to sit across
from her and the first lunch and so
scared to even open my mouth like oh my
gosh a something stupid and she's gonna
know I'm a fraud and I don't know what
I'm doing and you know and every was so
great and gracious and wanted to be in
it like oh my god and seeing Kyla in
these commercials these Nike commercials
and seeing myself as a little girl and
knowing that that was young Monica and
now how do I get her in the movie and
begging an eleven-year-old please please
be a part of this like to see all these
stages and how much fight it took to get
to get this made to be in this place now
I honestly I wish I could figure it out
why and bottle it and put it into every
film but you know maybe that that's a
thing everything doesn't get to do that
but I think I think just the experience
and the people involved or what made it
so special how do you think this
experience influenced the films that you
went on to wanna make in the films that
you have made in our making mm-hmm well
I would say honestly the most important
thing that it is done for me is the
knowledge that I just need one yes
because every movie except for Sigma
lucky B's has been a fight to get made
but knowing how hard this one was how
many knows how I had to overcome now to
get it made gives me the courage to to
you know write things that may not be
initially thought to be commercial but
it's something that I believe in so I
think that honestly is the most
important thing and then I think just
growing as a filmmaker of my experience
with with these actors and and things
that Alfred taught me I've taken on
every set and in soon a nice
relationship and in coming to become
friends and and being able to talk to
her as a director actor when I'm gonna
go do another film and just my
relationship with actors which is just
the most important thing to me
and building that trust it's a you know
certainly have taken those things that's
cool
yeah and then it's funny you're talking
about denying your relationship here's
what's funny I never knew about the
casting process or anything and so it
was funny when I started getting ready
for this panel cuz I was like god this
is like the match made in heaven this is
like the but like it's such a great
performance it reminds me of you and
it's a kind of woman that I have never
seen before it holds it what's amazing
about it is the the Sanai you hold the
cards very close to your vest but yet
you're so emotive at the same time and
giving such a great performance and
there's such a subtlety to that so I was
shocked when I ended up hearing that it
was this long road I actually totally
understand it I can't imagine if you're
trying to cast someone to play
basketball the circles that you would go
in it actually made perfect sense to me
but um we actually have a clip to show
from a 2001 panel that Eugenia did at
the Academy's Samuel Goldman Theatre of
a to a group of high school students and
in it you talk about casting and I'd
love to know if this is still the way
you remember it now the hardest thing
for me and I've talked us and not about
this so it's not like I'm below nor up
here the the hardest thing was casting
Monica it's like I knew the script works
I got the whole cast together couldn't
find someone to play Monica I looked for
actors I look for athletes you know
actors would come in and lie and say
they could play ball so I put him on the
court and it was just embarrassing so
finally I just said I'm gonna go with an
athlete and teach him how to act but you
know there were so many things that the
character Monica had to be and she and
going up against people like Omar and
alfre woodard just an audition again the
people that I did I looked at just we're
not strong enough so you know I knew
Sanaa because she had done the reading
for me and helped me actually get the
movie made and if I never seem to do
that she probably never would have had a
shot because she'd never played
basketball in her life before this movie
so
you know she worked out for four months
and you know go watch her practices and
I was just scared to death because I was
like you know if if you don't believe
her as a ballplayer the movies not gonna
work and again I was able to trust her
she weren't she played six days a week
every day for three months training and
I mean I don't even play that much when
when I was playing so you know it was
just being able to trust her and I still
didn't know if I'd made the right
decision until the first day of dailies
when I looked at the film and saw
sonam's performance and how good she was
acting wise and I said well we'll just
make the basketball work and you know we
did some creative cutting but you know
she worked her butt off and you know
learned to play I have the exact same
Wow
yeah that is you know it's it's all true
I I yeah the fact that Sanada in this
movie is a miracle and it was because of
the reading that she did and as we joked
she almost got fired from the reading
okay she also got fired from the reading
because because we had the table read
for it and she comes from theater and I
didn't know she was just reading the
lines and I was like god she sucks like
and I told Ridge after I was like oh my
god what am I gonna do this is like
everybody's coming to this producers I
got to do something man I tried to call
somebody and they didn't pick up thank
God they did not pick up and I said I'm
gonna have to just like go with this and
so stressed out and I gave likes Nasim
Wack Wack Wack that puck she just looked
at me like yourselves dude but we start
the reading and literally the second she
open her mouth
was a different person it was Monica and
it was such a magical night the reading
was amazing Spike Lee's company was
there I could not stop hugging so not
after but she was so good and so that
performance was stuck in my head during
casting and we saw hundreds of girls I
always feel like it was a certain
element of destiny involved because you
had another actress who was gonna do the
reading so the day before and she got
sick it was like two days before the the
table read yeah it was scary yeah yeah
and it was your dad like I was just
starting to work in LA I was getting a
lot of gifts back so I was doing myself
and I got a call from my dad because you
guys had a relationship and he was like
there's this young up-and-coming
director who has this script and there's
a table read and me coming from theater
and having done so many plays and now
that I was getting paid to do these
guest spots I was like I'm not doing no
stage reading because law and order was
more important yeah exactly
I mean I know what it was I had you
ready yet and I don't think that I got
to read the whole script before so I
almost it was like one of those things
we look back and you're like thank God
cuz I could have easily just been like
no no thanks there's always that element
of Destiny that you just don't
understand
no no so yeah so I saw a ton a ton of
women nobody was right so I had to not
come in to read with Omar and the
chemistry was just insane and so I just
didn't know what to do though at that
point because she had never touched a
ball it wasn't even that yeah I don't
play basketball so now I had never
picked up a basketball in her life and I
said I would never do that to female
athletes I couldn't set us back you know
years I haven't
whack up there so Sanaa started with
having a brother trainer and then she
rightfully said look if I'm gonna keep
going through this process then you need
to hire me a trainer and you know she
was right to advocate for herself so we
hired a woman who was a assistant coach
of the sparks to trainer and so she
trained in three months with no
guarantee of the part because I cannot
make a decision because I just really
wanted Natalie and but it finally once
again her dad called me so this is the
thing that's crazy everybody was like
just you know this it doesn't look like
you're gonna get this job just drop out
but I had this one woman who was kind of
a mentor to me and she was like you're
learning a new skill you're learning
basketball is it fun and I was like yeah
she was like we'll just do it for the
fun stop worrying about getting the job
and so that's actually that one piece of
advice is what kept me going thank God
but finally her dad called me up to
three months and said you know what
you're doing is abusive and he was right
and I I had two tapes I had sonam's tape
and I had a ball player tape who was
with an acting coach at the same time
they were on these parallel tracks and
you know I sat down I'll keep bringing
up his name but it's true Reggie my
husband said you know what what is this
is this a love story or is it a
basketball film and so you know when I
really thought about it it was a love
story set in the world the basketball
and I knew that you know you could fake
a jump shot you can't fake a close-up
and and so I said I gotta go with Sanaa
Dena so that's so interesting it's still
stunning to me even though I also
understand it for you like how how did
you go about creating the character
because like I said I I there was so
much on the page I see a lot of Gena but
obviously you're a great actress so you
made it into something very very
authentic yourself and even became a
basketball player how was your process
of creating that character well in
hindsight even though it was that going
for the part
and before you know all of the training
and auditioning and like kind of having
to prove myself for four months before
getting the part the you know quoting
quote abusive part which you know that
in a weird way prepared me for Monica
because it's kind of her journey it's
all about you know proving herself and
having a vision for her light and her
self that is unconventional
that people don't believe in and so and
then the actual physicality of like I
was carrying or I was in I think a
Monica before before we even started
before I got the job like I would where
I'm such a girly girl and I love you
know all things very feminine and I knew
that I wanted Monica to be different
than that and so I was wearing big
basketball shorts and carrying a
basketball around my friends were
looking at me like I was crazy I was
like they were like what are you doing
and that partially came from Colleen my
coach who was a real coach for sparks
she was amazing and she was part of the
part of the reason like she kind of like
infused the joy of the game and the joy
of being competitive and she we had fun
with actually playing with character
while I was doing the drills on the
court so she was actually helpful in
kind of getting that kind of Monica
swagger but we actually have a couple of
pre-screened questions from fans to the
group this one is sort of - Gina but it
came in four on from facebook from
tatianna from Los Angeles and the
question is Gina you spoke so elegantly
on the gender gap particularly for black
female directors in the documentary half
the picture considering the climate of
today do you see an increase in black
female directors having the option to
direct their own contents and do you see
a rise in Hollywood's green light green
lighting stories with black female
protagonists
I mean yeah okay I can there's positives
I'll start positively there are more
women getting the opportunity and there
are some dope young women coming up I'd
you know
Alfred's movie clemency you know that's
a talented filmmaker and this woman who
did miss Juneteenth and so there are
some young women coming up and I know
that those of us the very few of us that
are in this definitely feel the
responsibility when we see talent to to
reach back and and let's pull some more
folks in every time I get excited though
about oh my gosh we're getting more
opportunities and then the numbers come
out and black women are think it's 2
percent of directors that are making
movies in this industry which is so
staggering to me so for me I have to
keep my head down and not think about
those numbers because then you just get
depressed and just focus on that I have
stories that I want to tell and I have
to overcome now and I can't worry about
the numbers I just have to do the best
work that I can so that I can continue
to tell the stories and also I know that
in my success others will have success
as well and that's that's what I focus
on so I think it's important that
filmmakers coming up don't focus on the
numbers you can't you just have to focus
on the work and focus on being great and
reaching for greatness and that is all
you can focus on and that you hope that
and I I do believe that if you're
writing something really good it will
find a voice in the space
so yeah just focus on the work couldn't
agree with you more I think that's a
such a good answer
Alfre I have a question for you you have
done so many incredible pieces of work
my favorite thing about your performance
here is obviously you are someone who is
ambitious sent an order
and all of these things but you brought
such an honesty in your performance of a
very different kind of woman and to over
a relationship with your daughter that I
rarely see like I I feel like that the
mother character is so often turned into
a cliche of some sort of thing so what
was what was that process for you like
and and how was it taking on that role
first of all I was completely struck by
the girl genius when I picked a fast
script it was one of the most
beautifully rendered scripts I've ever
written it was smart
it was exciting it was authentic on so
many levels and and then I met Jean I
was really excited to meet her I was I
was probably just like you know I could
have been hailed her like Messiah is
here she is just she covers all the
bases and the thing is I grew up as an
athlete and so I was super excited about
it but then I didn't really want to be
the mom because that's no fun especially
somebody says you sweat too much it's
like oh damn I want to be in it I want
to be anywhere near but and then as we
talked and and Gina you said to me that
it was more or less your experience with
your mom growing up and how she was not
of the same mind that you were as an
athlete then I was very protective of
that you know what you got to represent
and you got to be Gina's Monica's mom
here and you know what one of the things
that people don't do is that when you
are of a this is why I think people
don't do mom's well hmm a lot of the
best writers I'm not talking about the
pedestrian ones certainly not the
mediocre ones but that period what we
would really know who a mommy
that's a period for us when parts of my
brain as a teen has shut down so we can
love them or we can rebel against them
but we really don't see women and so so
I always feel responsibility to to help
find the real woman in a mom and
although it was very exciting I you know
it was yeah it is legitimate to because
it comes out of love every you know
that's the thing is you when people are
trying to correct you even if they're
being incorrect with it the thing that a
lot of us miss and misinterpret in life
and in reinterpreting life for this
screen is is where where is the impulse
to correct coming from and yeah I found
on certain days I could read the book
instead of watch the action on the floor
which was a big thing for me I need to
be anywhere near Gina I mean girl when
you think about it that script you can't
believe the efforts that I've had to
read through the years and to get a
script like that where just like in fire
and also cylinders it covered the bases
looking on my cliches and and and I was
turning the page and so now yes I was
emotional then I got pumped up then I
got all kind of horny is like oh my god
is this we have turned a corner here and
yeah I was it was very exciting and I
the thing that made me most excited was
that it was a young person it was a
woman and she was a colored person so
that meant that there was a whole world
that exists that we all live in and
middle class for God's sakes you have to
believe it was like oh my god I would
know these people the daddy sitting
there
they having dinner and they got nice
cars they go to jobs you know they were
they were people that we all grew up
with and knew so all those reasons but
especially that I knew I would get to
see I get to hear from this boys
talk a little bit you ants and I'd love
to talk a little bit about that [ __ ]
that you know crescendo altercation in
the kitchen because I thought it was so
I could feel the depth of all of the
dynamic all along but talk a little bit
about doing that scene because I feel
like once again it's a scene that we've
seen Oh mom you know that that kind of
moment many times before but I'd love to
hear about the experience of finding
that moment together
I remember you know I was prepared
emotionally for the scene I knew that I
wanted monitor was she crying in the inn
she cried in the script right was it
written or I knew I hadn't made a
decision that I wanted her to cry anyway
it was one of those things where all the
emotion was there and every time we got
to the point this there was a slap and
every time we got to it and it was a you
know fake slap it wasn't coming but it
was all there and then all of a sudden I
got a real slap and everything came and
altri said oh my god I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to do that but you don't
have to say anything I'll free I know
she did it for me do you know what I
mean I knew she did it for me I knew it
was a loving and you know I had been
onstage getting slapped eight shows a
week so that wasn't a thing for me you
know what I mean it actually really
helped me you do whatever it takes to
get there and get it you know on screen
so I am forever grateful for the slap I
tell you that was the that are the
hardest thing I had to do in the whole
celeb
I had never hit either my children ever
I got smacked every day of my life
growing up but I have a hard time I
can't cuss people out but I can't really
especially somebody I
love you know I just have a hard time so
I knew that I was getting there I was
like I knew I was stopping myself and
and your face is so pretty in my soul
there's not a mark on I was like oh no
but and you actually had some little
redness I me kind of well I started just
real quick the what I did in that scene
learned something tremendous as well and
I'm sure you've come across this too
I was so close when the real slap
happened it was such a shock and I
almost yelled cut and I would have shot
myself if I had done that but like the
fact it wasn't that I mean that
performance is in the movie you know and
so to understand that sometimes the
actors need to do things for each other
that you know I wasn't able to give in
that moment but that's okay you know and
for me to almost below that moment it's
still a shock to me but again to give in
and let them have that and let them
figure it out it was a really amazing
lesson to to watch those two yeah that's
so cool because I have seen that too
and I have definitely had my moments
where particularly with child actors
where the other actor will start to
literally direct that and you end up in
this beautiful case where you're
watching you're watching them take care
of each other and I'm not surprised I
can feel that in that scene that that
they're so connected that's such a great
story well it's a great scene and it's a
great relationship as a result of it um
so Kyla I was gonna ask you so here's
you you had such an incredible presence
and and and and such a such emotion you
were such a young person I can't believe
you're 11 years old that shocks me um
what was it like for you to not only
take on playing such an unusual
character and doing so many different
things but you're also living up to a
great actress who's doing another
another version of that how did you go
about forming that character for
yourself and how much
watching Sandoz performance or how did
you do that um it was it's weird because
looking back on it it's like I was 11
like I literally was like wait I keep
said be in a movie where I can play
basketball and I can beat up on boys and
act like a boy like oh this is gonna be
fun so the character was so close to me
cuz that's who I was at the time growing
up like I grew up with all brothers like
I was playing basketball
I was extremely rough and I was like
okay well let me just let me just have
fun with it you know I I think that's
one of the best parts of me being a
child actor and being a part of so many
amazing things and being a part of
something as amazing as this is that um
there wasn't I didn't feel a lot of
pressure put on me it was just like have
fun with it and we have a coach for you
like I coached with Scott Elena's little
how good a coach for you go go shoot
with her and and and I think I think the
only time I really did so the pressure
was like okay I got it look like I hope
like I know I bet I know I play
basketball a little bit but I got to
look like I do this like I'm gonna and I
think that still follows me to this day
like anything that I'm a part of I'm
like okay no I got to look like I really
do this and I really have to make sure
that I'm breathing in every part of this
character and I think it probably
started being so young and being a part
of something like lemon basketball where
it was like okay I can't I can't look
crazy
I gotta I gotta get with them you know
these buckets you know so you know has
has has helped me in this industry and
and why I'm still able to be here and
giving me the drive to you know want to
become the character and really and
really give their story and just every
time I sit back and watch this movie I
just flash back to the premiere and I'm
just like you obviously were so young
that you that you experienced all kinds
of things and I know you've been asked
about this before but all kinds of
things on set for the first time which
has got to be like such a such a strange
thing
but apparently your kiss is your first
real kiss which I can't I just imagine
directing but I definitely can't imagine
acting at the age of 11 so um we
actually have a clip of Gina talking
about rehearsing that moment and
actually was cute as those who actually
started dating after the movie awesome
that was that was a Tyler's first kiss
in real life so it was pretty funny you
know at the beginning of a movie before
you shoot you do rehearsal and so I had
to rehearse that with them so that they
wouldn't be scared on the set because
you know there's like 4050 people
standing around watching them kissing
you know when you're 12 years old that's
a big deal so uh you know the parents
are there rehearsal I made the parents
leave out the room and you know they
kept we do the scene and right before
they got to the kiss part they start
laughing and run you know two opposite
sides of the room and it's just happened
and over and over so fine and said you
know just kiss her on the cheek and so
that's how it started and then finally
you know glendon who's a little boy just
you know I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
it and just kissed her and once once the
first one happened it got easier for him
Lyndon is not that little boy anymore
he's a big ol play in it no fan I'm
wearing come on help me out
so Kyle how is what is your other side
of that story like what's your memory
that's crazy is that some of that I
barely remember her and then I saw Gina
talking about it and I was like oh my
that is what it had been like I didn't
even I remember having to do the
rehearsal but I didn't remember like us
running away and playing and stuff like
that and and it actually I guess helped
because when you're younger like
everybody's going to eventually have
their first kiss but it's a good excuse
as - for work it was I was working like
it didn't just happened randomly at
school or like what he's talking about
but I just remember being um shy and a
little embarrassed in that moment and
not really what to make of it like I
said I wasn't really like into boys at
that point
and I was like just starting and I was
like hey you know um having my little
you know childhood moment and I got to
blame it on B Network I have to say Kyla
you see how she is I mean she's just
bubbly and and that day it was a
different day the kiss you were just
like just quiet I switch it up I try to
I try to maintain my my good energy but
you're not you know I've learned that
over the years terilyn we haven't gotten
to talk to you about this yet and it's a
perfect time really because it's funny
you you you did such a beautiful job on
this film but it's interesting to be now
looking back on it after all of this
time and hearing what the film came into
what were your ambitions I don't know if
you'd met Jana before but like when you
read the script I know every film has
its challenges but every film also has
its wonderful ambitions to do to kind of
bring to life things that you haven't
had a chance to do what was your
approach to it when you first read the
script like what was your biggest desire
for it yeah I mean I think that it you
know when you read a script as an editor
and you read a really good script it's
like breathing rare air right and when I
went in to meet with Gina I mean the
thing about Gina is she is the best
poker player as far as you know like you
do not know what she's thinking
and so you know there's this there's
this confidence that you have and what
you know your ability is but you have to
still go into a room and you know talk
to a director and and and convince them
why you should be the person to sit next
to them for hours on end and I just
remember kind of talking to her about
things I loved about the script and you
know she was listening and and you know
acrost me and at the same time I had no
idea what she was thinking and I
remember leaving the meeting not even
you know did that go well I just I could
and but I just had so many thoughts so
many thoughts about the script and why I
loved it and why I connected with it and
why you know I wanted to be a part of it
and that you know I think he alternately
I felt like I needed to I there was more
I wanted to say she needed to know how
good the movie she was about to make you
know how much we needed it and how you
know and so that part of it was great
and and and getting getting the that
opportunity to take that journey with
Gina is one that I I treasure and
learned so much from you know I wasn't a
basketball player I mean I was a swimmer
in high school so you know different
different skill set so it was really a
great opportunity to really talk about
it sitting with the director and just
getting you know I work in both
performance but also the technical
aspect of who Monica had to be as an
athlete that's great and and when during
the process and by the way that really
shows you you can feel that when during
the process did you start to really see
that something special was happening or
did you always know it because of the
scripts the script and the dailies and
what you were able to do with them or
was there a moment that it really
started to kind of come together I think
in some ways as the daily started coming
in and the performances were just you
know so real you know
and Monica's vulnerability was so
palpable I knew that I knew that I knew
we had the performances I knew we had
that and I trusted in getting to know
Gina and I I did go to set a couple
times that she was going to work for as
long as it took to get that other part
right and that it was going to just be
able to take you know her coming in to
make the adjustment she needed to make
you know showing the first cut to a
director is always fraught with you know
I can't you know I know it's I can't
imagine what it's like for you guys
to to sit there for the first time and
for an editor you know you're ready to
kind of you're ready to move on you're
ready to start working and yet you know
that there's this moment that you guys
have to process what you just saw and
that part was hard and and right after
the the cut it took Gena good I don't
know couple weeks to just settle into
that we were going to be okay
was going to be okay and that but I
think that really for me there were so
many moments of just being able to have
the footage come in and just be able to
enjoy as an audience before I got to the
editing part of it what was coming what
was coming in well speaking of seeing
the film we have someone who saw the
film many years ago and and they were
influenced by it and as much as they've
you know this film was influenced by
basketball and Gina you should help me
with this introduction because I think
that you know you have more to say but
we have a special guest who is the
forward for the LA Sparks Candace Parker
Hey
hi everybody thank you yes you're
listening to this this is like their
goals right now for me just FYI hey I'd
say like Candace is just like my hero
such a dope baller and just so change
the game and and and you play the
Tennessee which is what I wanted to play
Glenda played for Pat Summitt so bad but
the things that you accomplished and
like I'm so enamored by people who are
great at what they do and you are great
in too so to have you on this call is
just really amazing to me and and I
sincerely appreciate it and I wish this
was in person but you know this is the
close closest I get to you but thank you
for being here
no I really appreciate it I mean this
movie was my life like I mean you talk
about just the impact that the W me I
started in 97 this movie came out when I
was 14
it was just right when I fell in love
with basketball and it was so much so
that you know in high school everybody
knew of my
favorite basketball movie was everybody
knew what my favorite movie was you
could not tell me I wasn't Monica Wright
and that in fact I got so much right I
got the money right loving basketball
Crenshaw jersey every every line to the
movie so this gives me so much joy to be
able to tell you how influential this
movie was where a person is growing up
playing basketball inspiring to to play
professionally so it just means so much
to be on this call oh that's that's
amazing I have to say was you know like
it was I just won all players to love it
and and that's why it was so important
is why castings are not why it was such
a big deal and in needing to get her
right I never wanted anybody to look up
on screen and and not see a female
baller and the female athlete and
everything that that is because it was
such a part of me and so good to have
your cosign you know is is really
everything that I wanted for this and
again all props to Sanaa for putting
putting in that work and my editor Terry
for making her look good and I mean you
did that yourself snuff but a little
help but yeah that that's amazing to see
well I think it was just the progression
as well like I grew up playing against
voice in Kyle I mean she did an amazing
job representing all of us out there
that's moms wanted us to wear dresses
come back with the dresses all messed up
and I had a best friend growing up that
was a boy we be in the driveway playing
basketball all the time and competing
and so it was just the entire movie I
mean I literally got dressed out to LA
and I had a daughter the next year it
was just like I mean in my mind it might
be so it was just um the movie is has
such an impact on the culture just as
the female athlete and that being
important as anything in the movie
mm-hmm can you tell us a little bit
about the first time you
like did you know it was coming did you
know because it was such an unusual
thing for a girl who is playing ball it
must have been so unusual to see
something like that had you heard it was
coming my parents I had seen the the
signs around and my parents actually
took me to see it and my team was there
and I just remember you know it was
right during that perfect time and I
can't say it enough of female athletes
saying like okay I can play basketball
for a profession okay
female athletes are actually getting
represented notice and so just I
remember sitting there watching it with
my parents and then when it finally came
on on you know to to buy I had the video
I mean every boyfriend I had I think
we've watched every watched 11
basketball and so it just has really had
an impact on me that's so great and
Candace I know you you can't stay with
us for the whole duration so I wanted to
I had one more question for you which
was how did that whole augmentation of
the basketball how did that end up
working how is that a part of why the
movie spoke to you because I thought
that was such an incredible thing for me
who doesn't play basketball like just
the way it was filmed and the experience
what was your impression of like seeing
your sport that way it was so important
to see you know the actual action shots
and so not listen you did an amazing job
playing basketball I mean you Quentin
see you know he he didn't do a layup as
as well as you did you looked the part
and played the part so if we're if we're
picking teams I'm picking you but I
think just the representation of putting
your heart and your soul into things I
mean there's a scene in there where she
gets in trouble and gets a technical and
that's been a topic of discussion for a
long time in female sports is if we show
emotion we're not acting ladylike but
emotions is sport so that really spoke
to me about you know there's a scene
where she
like you know if he does that he gets
patted on his butt but if I do that you
know I get told I have attitude so
there's just scenes in there that you
show in college and just the transition
of that I played for Coach Summitt as we
spoke about earlier and you know the hot
dogging the holding the follow-through
and having to to stand there and do that
again I mean it was just seeing
basketball represented in a way that it
actually happened it really spoke to me
just individually and I was an athlete
and so great you know any last thing to
add for Candace I'm so happy you were
here you're just you know such an
impressive person and it's so great you
were here to pop in on this and join
yeah and I just you know I look forward
to when you get to play ball again
hopefully this will go away and yeah I
look forward to just yeah go into a game
and see me play life right thank you all
so much I really appreciate it yes I can
this so we only have one more question
and it's for everybody um how did you
all feel when the movie was released and
and when you finally got to see it for
those of you who hadn't seen it um I
felt I was so excited because everything
that I felt just being on set with you
know a young woman in charge who was not
who was being herself and I realized I
I'd have to look at the filmography but
I think that's the first time I had a
female in charge of a set and I mean I'd
had something like episodic directors
but and but the whole crew and and our
guys because it was a very masculine set
the guys over there but there was none
of that energy that where they even come
with like you know the kind of you know
whipping it out contest that can happen
with with men on cruises and in cast
everybody's like you know so it was it
was so I had a reaction there it was
like I don't care what else
happens and I had you know Kyla you guys
were just I was so excited that that and
so fulfill that that that that day had
come just in the shooting of it so when
I finally saw it I was it was like you
know we had one that you know we were
you know you know March Madness but the
thing that happened was it it gave me a
legitimacy in a lot of circles and I
didn't have before for friends that
weren't filmmaker all of that and so it
just completely opened up my life and
like I said I was just riding a sidecar
with this so it's something that I've
just been you know I never say oh proud
to do this part of it but I've been
proud of been in that company no
phenomena for me as an actor I love I
really I believe that what we do is is
can be spiritual work and I and I take
such a deep pride in in putting things
out there into the world that truly
touch people and this is one of those
that did and it's still doing it and so
that just makes me so happy
okay and I would say for me um of course
I told you guys about being at the
premiere and being wide-eyed and just
lost in the story
what's amazing for me is that I we shot
it when I was so young so every time I
do watch it every time I've maybe I
watched it again at 16 and then again
and throughout the years and and you
know you grow up and you mature so every
time I would watch out and get something
new from what about you Terry well you
know the first time being able to watch
it with an audience you know there's an
editor saying that you know you know
you're done with a film when you stop
seeing the cuts where you can just sit
and watch it as you know we
we become an audience member again and
that's what I remember is being able to
just sit in the audience with everybody
else and feel like you know we got this
right mm-hmm
that's great well you know what was it
like for you when you finally got to see
it with an audience as officially
finished film it said well if we kind of
had to I had two experiences that were
really important the first audience
preview first and only we did it in
Crenshaw of like audience and it was so
raucous and amazing it was like it felt
it felt amazing to just be in that
environment and to have people feel the
way they felt about the film so vocally
so that was the first and then we then
very shortly after went to Sundance and
had that and that was 1300 people and it
was 99% white audience so totally
different and I remember at the very end
very last scene the movie ends and it
was dead silent and I remember literally
in my head I said well I guess they
didn't get it suddenly the crowd erupted
and I mean I don't know if you feel this
way paddy for me when you're making a
film and all these people come together
and the fact that they trusted me all I
wanted was to make sure I did what I
said I was gonna do so that I didn't
fail them that I that they didn't come
on a ride that that wasn't gonna come to
fruition it was like that thing drives
me like Alfred Woodard trusted me and so
I couldn't I didn't want to fail for
that and for every person that believed
in it and for Mike DeLuca and like all
these people in spite that stood up for
me to fight to give me this opportunity
I did not want to fail
them so to sit and hear an audience
respond and know that that we made a
good film like it's it's an amazing
feeling just it's an amazing feeling
well congratulations because you did not
fail and not only did you not fail we're
here 20 years later having a reunion
about your film Gina so congratulations
and honestly congratulations to all of
you we all everybody you've all done
such great work and everybody aspires
all the time to do things that reach
people and touch people but not
everybody gets to be a part of films
that you do come back and talk about 20
years later because people are coming up
to all the time so congratulations to
all of you it's a huge accomplishment to
make something that resonates in that
way and I want to say thank you to
everybody that tuned in to this it's
been such a fun thing to do I so enjoyed
it and hearing everybody's answers and
so thanks for streaming this and
remember that you can stream love and
basketball all kinds of places Google
Play YouTube iTunes Vudu Amazon Prime so
tune in and and thanks for being here
thanks so much for doing